[snorts]
>> It's [music] confession time.
I've been losing to the same deck since
2020.
Seriously, my record against it is
probably [music] something like 0 to 12.
And I didn't realize why until 6 years
later.
>> [music]
>> Every time I just wrote it off as RNG.
But when it happened again [music] just
a few weeks ago, I realized what had
occurred was all part of a sinister
plan.
Hello, my name is Jin and obviously I'm
the main character, the protagonist of
my playgroup. But my friend Johnny, he's
a bit like the knight on the chessboard.
Doesn't stand out as much. You're not as
worried about him, but once in a while
he swoops in with some devastating decks
and big brain plays that can do some
serious damage.
The prime example of this is his Pako
and Haldan.
They're a set of side commanders from
precon C20 and let's just say they did
not stand out.
I mean, yes, things were slower back
then, but we already got legends like
Ayula, Uril, Kinnan, all these commander
legend partners. Not to mention from the
same deck, Kykar, the Raging Storm. All
these cards that basically combo with
themselves. And then we have these two
idiots that take up two positions to do
the job of one. See, I thought it would
look more like this if the design team
was competent and they weren't trying to
force the partners mechanic, I thought.
So, when Johnny first brought out this
deck, I was not worried. I focused on my
friend Alex who played much stronger
partners in Jeskai and Tevesh. "Ah,
we'll see what the dog exiles and then
respond accordingly," I thought.
Pretty quickly though, I found myself
staring down a 12/12 with nine commander
damage on me already. I died without
even seeing Haldan get put on the stack
and so did Alex. And then it happened
several times in the months following.
It just so happened the dog somehow
lived long enough, we ignored it. I
depleted my resources answering other
bigger threats, I thought.
Now, fast forward to 2026, just a few
days ago Johnny brought this deck out
again.
But it's 2026, I have the newest tech
with much better understanding of the
game. No way I'm losing to this again.
But then Johnny proceeded to destroy me
with that same dog, but with a few new
tricks. His split second protection
spell blanked my two removal spells. He
also had pump, extra combat, all that to
kill me and the other players. And that
was when I realized that this was never
a steal deck.
Or rather, it's both. His game plan is
two parts and he almost never needed to
go to part two.
Start off with a Voltron matter that
scales incredibly quickly, and if that
fails, we fall back on the Halden plan
with a dozen cards exiled. And I was
wrong about another thing in that the
steal and the use effect being on two
different creatures is not a downside,
but rather it allows the deck to start
part two of his game plan without any
commander tax, fresh. And the deck
barely needs any support for Halden. All
we really need is some consistent early
game ramp, which is also helpful for
powering out the five mana doggo. Aside
from that, we'll just try to win the
game with the spells we steal and maybe
power the dog out for a few more hit and
runs if it's not completely out of the
picture. Now, that's a sweet deck.
I've seen decks with two separate game
plans, of course, but never is the Venn
diagram so perfectly aligned. And even
better, this deck can absolutely be
built on a budget around $100 since
there's no expensive core engine. The
doggo is the engine. Commander centric.
I'll include both lists down in the
descriptions. Now, the list is mostly
built as if we only have Paco as our
commander with a little extra ramp.
Okay, well, a lot of ramp. 21 pieces.
Because we're probably not worried about
running out of cards to use. Our only
limit is mana. We've got all the classic
ramp spells, but we're also playing
these three. One, because they help us
manipulate our top deck a little bit,
but also because Halden allows us to
play lands. So, in the late game, we can
also make good use of the lands in
exile.
So, ideally, we let the dog out on turn
three or turn four with protection.
Yeah, we need a lot of those as well, 14
pieces. Starting with an equipment in
Conqueror's Flail. It takes a bit of
setting up, but once it's equipped, our
opponents have no choice but to watch
what we're about to do to them.
Teamwork gives us excellent variety from
cheap counter spells to redirects to
these protection pump effects. Also, a
few of these interesting ones that give
evasion. Yeah, now that we're getting
some fetch triggers consistently, why
not get some damage in as well? Evasion.
Artful dodge is awesome. Wing boots is
also a decent protection and trample.
Rancor, scepter, and river cleaver. Oh,
yeah, also Embercleave. Now, Embercleave
doesn't just do evasion. The double
strike can destroy some people. Yeah,
double strike is good. We're also
playing some of these double strike
spells, but they have to do something
else cuz they're a bit narrow. So,
either can trip cycle or they come with
an equipment or Inferno, which we can
also use to copy something big later in
the game. But, the best finishers are
these extra combat cards because we're
getting extra fetch triggers. We try to
keep the cost down with seize the day,
overpowering attack, and great train
heist. We're also willing to splurge on
mana, but these have to be game winning,
and they are. Genji gloves, savage
beating, and full throttle.
Also, Moraug synergizes so well with our
ramp spells, it's hard to exclude.
Again, we don't need too much card draw.
The doc should have that mostly covered,
but some of these are really efficient.
We I think they're worth playing.
Hunter's insight, terrors and biosis can
get us two to four cards a turn, and
lightstream's blessing to recoup some
life. Just a few pieces of miscellaneous
utility. We're mostly relying on our
opponents to provide us with answers,
but us getting beat up while Paco
charges in is a concern. So, I have
Neheb, the Eternal Flame, and Chandra's
ignition. Usually, these are a bit
risky, but with the amount of protection
we have, it's much more reliable and
devastating. Meanwhile, constant mist is
a ridiculous magic card. We don't need
to be locking combat completely, but
just a two or three turns of immunity at
the cost of two lands is close to
Teferi's protection level, if not
better.
And finally, just a few pieces that
synergize with Haldan, passionate
archaeologist, keeper of secrets, and
Nafashni. These are not really
necessary, but can lead to pretty fun
plays, and they're especially helpful if
we're staring down the one final
opponent. For lands, the most important
land for any deck like this one is
Witch's Clinic. Imagine the clinic on a
10/10 doggo with Chandra's Ignition on
the stack. That's the dream with
protection spell backup, of course.
Aside from that, we are prioritizing
evasion, got to get the dog through, and
protection in Talons Gate and Plaza of
Heroes. The Kamigawa lands are nice
because if we have use for them, we can
just cast Helden and play a land from an
opponent. So, there's that flexibility.
Also, MDFCs the same thing, and of
course, Alchemist's Refuge.
The best land for any big mana deck is
especially good here because in a pinch
I can flash in Helden and immediately
use anything from the exile piles.
And that's the list. Again, what I love
most about this deck is the two-part
game plan. But, unlike most other decks
with multiple game plans, we don't
suffer from the wrong half problem.
Everything we do is to push the dog for
more hits, and late game Helden alone
will take care of everything. It does
have some problems, though, the most
glaring one being, so if I send the dog
to kill people fast, I lose their cards
and Helden gets nerfed hard.
That is true. However, this also kind of
falls in line with how I prefer to play
Voltron decks because depleting all your
resources to kill one opponent fast, and
the other two take you out after seeing
what you are capable of, that's not fun.
So, personally, I prefer leaning more on
the value provided by our commander, and
chipping on each opponent evenly.
Only deliver the final blow when someone
is clearly running away with the game,
or when you have a solid plan to kill
all three in quick succession. But, the
truth is by late game, we should expect
to only be able to use our own cards and
maybe the resource of one opponent. So,
we do have to figure out who to kill
last
when we are presented with the option.
The deck does require a lot of
decision-making, especially when the
fetch pile begins to build up. Say it's
turn five, you're missing a land drop,
do you cast Helden to get a land? Also,
as mentioned earlier, which opponents to
go for. The deck isn't as explosive as
many other Voltron options, but the dog
does catch some people by surprise. I
rate it pretty high, though, for
resilience, more than most other Voltron
decks, at least, because they don't have
a part two. We do.
The deck's budget is fairly and it sits
somewhere between bracket two and three.
It's slightly slower than other Voltron
decks, so it doesn't feel quite as
oppressive. And Heldan's power level
adjusts based on your opponents. And
that's the deck. Again, deck lists are
down below. I've been making a lot of
deck lists and I plan to do more. But if
there's something aside from deck list
that you want me to talk about or cover,
please leave a comment and let me know.
Thank you for watching till the end. If
you enjoy this kind of content, drop a
like, and follow along for more content.
Yeah, thanks. I'll see you later.